another topic that's been coming up is
college uh uh
tuition being paid for biden first two
years
for everybody let's uh forgive ten
thousand dollars no let's give forgive
fifty thousand dollars
and then elizabeth warren says let's
forgive all the one and a half trillion
dollars
how are you affected by that if
all of that's being forgiven because
then it doesn't affect the colleges and
universities that go straight to sallie
mae and the lenders and the taxpayers
right
what do you think about what's being
proposed with you know paying for
college tuition of kids
well uh two questions you know first of
all
what's is it a good idea and the second
is what's its effect on us
well it can't be a good idea and the
reason is
of all of the things on earth that
somebody can give you
education is the last thing
that you can get as an entitlement and
the reason is
every minute that you're learning you're
concentrating
and it takes energy and discipline to do
it and the teacher can be brilliant and
you're not paying attention you learn
nothing
so the first step is to get a higher
education
you need to want one and be prepared to
sacrifice for it
so this idea that we're just going to
send everybody to college well what do
they do when they get there
used to be a distinction to go right and
you know the success rates in college
are miserably low now
so i don't think any of that's a good
idea and i don't think that's where the
problem is
now affecting us we don't take any of
that money right so we get
and the other thing is we get a small
percentage of our money
from the students last year it was seven
percent of the revenues of hillsdale
college came from the students and their
parents
and we're trying to make that number
zero now we have an unusual reason for
wanting to do that
we under you know we have an honor code
it's very difficult to get into
hillsdale college
and that's precious because you're going
to have to work
half the time the course is the same for
every student
and that means you don't like physics
never mind you got to take it you don't
like philosophy you got to take it
right so we need kids who
commit and they sign an honor code and
if we're not charging them
anything at all then we can ask for more
in the way of commitment from them and
that's the valuable thing that's what
makes success
i like that that's a very interesting
perspective on what you said there if
we're not
asking nothing from them we can expect
more
from them and you're only taking 350
kids a year anyway so it's not like
you're
opening it up to everybody and see
the other thing is we teach we have two
and a half million people
taking online courses at hillsdale
college and
those are free we don't ask any money in
them either right
and and there's there's about 70 000
people now i think
that have taken all 26 of the courses
we've done so far
and taken the exams and passed them
they've got a sort of undergraduate
education there
and you know we we you know we
we we have a we have a rule of action
first of all hillsdale college itself
the little nuclear reactor in remote
michigan
that has to burn hot and pure
you got to get the best kids the ones
that most want to be there
the faculty who are the most eloquent
and and able
and you got to make that thing a
treasure and then that thing can radiate
all over the country we've started what
charter schools now we've got eight more
forming right
and our kids go teaching them we're
about to start a master's degree program
in classical education
to get to build trained school leaders
you know so people can teach
others right and the thing is
this is an activity that has never been
you know at its peak it's never been a
profit-making activity
education is for young people who
haven't
established themselves yet and they take
some time before they start their career
and they improve their intellects and
their characters
so of course it's a charitable
enterprise you should do it efficiently
and you should do it as cheaply as
possible
and you should do it excellently and
you know when education was private
that was how it was you know used to be
uh 70 percent of the people it's about
went to liberal arts colleges now it's
16 percent
and where do they go now they go to the
second and third tier state universities
and uh that's a change right and those
places are not
teaching the good the true and the
beautiful
and uh be better if we train them and if
we if
students learned the history and
principles of their country
and what kind of thing they are and the
great
story of the past and philosophy
with its many contentions right
everybody you know
used to be a high school education
brought most of that stuff
so that's you know one of our problems
is
we've bureaucratized in education it's a
centralized top down
thing and you know republicans are
extensively responsible for that
and we need to liberate that right
charter schools is the great engine
you said republicans are responsible for
that why why is that
no child left behind act uh
in the first the two guys named bush
since reagan right
they both uh the the elder you know
they're fine people
by the way and i voted for him and would
vote for him again
uh you know depending on the alternative
but um
uh they thought that they could fix
education in america
from washington d.c and so they came up
with this diet
this idea of high-stakes testing
which means and then you know one of
them said to me
a senior guy in this george w bush
administration when they were about to
launch the no child left behind
act which was a disaster and had to
gotta be rid of
he said he said well we'd like you to
take the lead in this and i said it
sounds like a bad name
and he said bad name i said yeah i said
you've been in the classroom
somebody's always getting left behind
you got to go back and get them
but also some of them are going to just
get farther than others that's just how
it is
right and uh and then they thought
and they said well we're going to have
these national tests
and see schools all over america now
take two months off in the spring
and teach toward the test right
and that means the tests are driving
curriculum
and who writes the test right except the
education
elite it was the most foolish idea i've
ever heard
and it dominates education today k
through 12.
it's uh that's why i wanted you to tell
the history on that with uh
it's funny i said no child left behind
no family left behind you know it's a
concept of somebody is going to be left
behind because there is competition and
someone's going to be willing to do more
than the other person is
[Music]
you